[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce journal a présenté et préparé
par les équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le
lundi 30 mai au sommaire aujourd'hui
plus de quatre mille collégiens de la 6e
à la 3e se sont rendus à versailles pour
un pentathlon des arts au programme un
programme arts de la scène arts visuels
numériques architecture et littérature
une journée pour faire découvrir le
château et son histoire face à la
pénurie de personnel l'académie de
versailles organisé ce lundi 30 mai un
job dating objectif compléter ses
effectifs et préparer la rentrée
prochaine plus de 400 postes sont à
pourvoir dont les yvelines la rectrice
de l'académie sera avec nous pour faire
le point et puis l approche du premier
tour des élections législatives qui aura
lieu le 12 juin prochain nous faisons le
point sur les enjeux du scrutin à venir
dans les yvelines focus aujourd'hui sur
la 9e circonscription
[Musique]
je vous le disais plus de quatre mille
collégiens des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine devant participer à une
visite du château de versailles ce lundi
30 mai une initiative des deux
collectivités en partenariat avec
l'établissement public du château et
nous avons suivi les élèves du collège
marcel rouby de saint germain en laye à
la découverte des disciplines
artistiques au temps de louis xiv c'est
un reportage de nicolas landry
il a suffi d'un pas dans la galerie des
glaces pour conquérir leur coeur j'aime
beaucoup cette pièce avec tous ces
miroirs etc des races j'aime beaucoup
les tableaux qu'on a montré moi ce que
je préfère c'est la salle des glaces
elle est immense la kia jamais visité ch
et audio say say say c'est vraiment
magnifique parmi les quatre mille trois
cents collégiens des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine présent une cinquantaine
d'élèves du collège marcel robbie de
saint germain en laye dans ce théâtre
écriture ou peinture ils en apprennent
un peu plus sur les activités
artistiques de l'époque de louis xiv
une visite ludique et pédagogique ce
surtout montré la mise en place du
pouvoir absolu et versailles c'est le
symbole c'est symbolique de cette mise
en place du pouvoir
en france au xviie siècle on va essayer
d'en faire découvrir justement toutes
les oeuvres d'art à versailles donc le
mobilier
les appartements du roi de l'arène et
puis peut-être leur montrer justement
les tableaux les arts décoratifs
cette initiative est portée à travers un
partenariat entre les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine avec le
château de versailles et pour catherine
pégard voir ces collégiens visiter
l'édifice royal ravive des souvenirs
d'enfance je suis venu à peu près au
même âge visiter le château de
versailles avec mon école et on n'oublie
jamais puisqu'il m'a marqué sans doute
ce qu'il essaie d'arriver dans ce
château immense et d'être tout petit et
évidemment quand on grandit on pense
qu'il va prendre des dimensions plus
normal et ça n'est pas vrai maintenant
que je suis au château de versailles je
sais que ça reste un très grand château
2022 était la quatrième édition de cet
événement une première édition s'était
tenue en 2019 face au contexte sanitaire
de 2020 et de 2021 la visite avait eu
lieu en virtuel
et on va s'intéresser à présent une
opération humanitaire elle s'appelle
histoire de coeur et elle est lancée par
les deux maires de villepreux et de port
marly elle son bulletin récolté 24 mille
euros pour venir en aide à l'association
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque elle permet
à des enfants atteints de malformations
cardiaques qui ne peuvent pas être
traitées dans leur pays d'origine d'être
opéré en france une opération pour
laquelle les deux élus vont payer de
leur personne les explications de
patrick de patrice carmouze un véritable
coup de coeur sans mauvais jeu de mots
c'est ainsi qu'aider le lien entre
francine leca la fondatrice de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque et le maire de
villepreux jean baptiste à monique
francine leca c'est un personnage
professeur de médecine elle fut la
première femme chirurgien cardiaque en
france et elle a fondé en 1996
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
cette association permet à des enfants
atteints de malformations cardiaques
mais qui ne peuvent pas être opéré dans
leur pays d'origine d'être prises en
charge en france dont des centres de
chirurgie cardiaque pédiatrique et
d'être ainsi sauvé comme l'expliquent
francine leca ils étaient partis
souffreteux bleus fatigué et rentre en
pleine forme en ayant considère que kg
et c'est toujours la grande fierté des
familles d'accueil quand on les revoit
après l'opération ils nous disent tout
de suite il a pris trois kilos le ca c
et c'est vrai parce que je dis toujours
quand on mange bien et qu'on dort bien
c'est qu'on va bien mais pour s'occuper
de ses enfants
les loger les nourrir il faut bien
entendu des familles d'accueil bien sûr
mais ça c'est un appel pressant et
intense que je fais à toutes les
familles qui voudront pendant un mois et
demi environ de moyenne accueillir un
petit enfant
lui est de contribuer fortement à lui
redonner la santé à faire d'un petit
enfant souffreteux est malade un enfants
plein de vie c'est pour les familles une
lourde charge il faut le reconnaître
mais à bonheur toujours magnifique il
faut aussi de l'argent environ 12000
euros par enfant d'où l'opération une
histoire de coeur menée par jean
baptiste à monique lemaire de villepreux
et son collègue de port marly cédric pin
bas marine les deux villes vont s'allier
pour sauver deux enfants une soirée de
gala un concert sont d'ores et déjà
prévues mais plus encore les deux maires
vont mouiller le maillot et pas qu'un
peu ils vont en effet participer au
marathon des sables une centaine de
kilomètres de course à pied par jour
comme l'expliquent jean baptiste à
monique on partira bas le soir même du
concert d'ailleurs au domaine de
grand'maisons partira le 25 septembre
pour revenir le 2 octobre ces quatre
jours de course en autosuffisance
alimentaire c'est à dire qu'on peint
avec nos paquetages pendant lesquelles
jours on a que l'eau qui nous est
ravitaillé et après à nous de cheminée à
nous de dormir et planter nos tentes le
soir et puis
et bien supporté la chaleur supporter ce
supporter mutuellement ça on a
l'habitude on y arrivera et puis oui
aller mouiller le maillot parce que
l'idée c'est d'embarquer tout le monde
c'est de fédérer tout le monde autour de
ce projet là mais il faut qu'on puisse
montrer l'exemple il va nous falloir un
peu d'entraînement on va falloir qu'on
dégage un peu de temps dans nos agendas
assez chargé de deux mères pour nous
entraîner parce que comme le disait
cédric tout à l'heure l'abandon n'est
pas une option une opération dont tv 78
partenaires nous suivrons évidemment de
près la course de ces deux mères qui
s'engage pour que des bouts d'choux
condamnés puissent mener la vie normale
d'un enfant quoi de plus beau
et c'est un job dating à venir pour de
l'accueil du prêt-à-porter ou encore de
la restauration les anciennes de
westfield parly 2 recrute ce mercredi
1er juin un job dating organisé en
partenariat avec pôle emploi la mairie
et la mission locale de versailles près
de 90 postes sont à pourvoir dans ce
centre commercial qui est implanté aux
chaînés rocancourt pour participer il
vous suffit de vous rendre sur place
entre 14h et 17h30 motivé et muni de
votre cv ça se passe pas porte au nez on
entre les magasins hema et uniqlo
et puis côté politique à présent les
yvelinois seront appelés aux urnes pour
élire leurs représentants de leur
circonscription à l'assemblée nationale
les 12 et 19 juin al'approche du premier
tour des élections législatives la
rédaction de tv 78 vous aide à y voir un
peu plus clair nous faisons le point sur
les enjeux de ce scrutin à venir dans
les yvelines et focus aujourd'hui sur la
9e circonscription c'est avec vous c'est
une charles bout ce soir en soir donc à
ce que vous pouvez déjà nous dire
quelles sont les communes qui sont
concernés par cette 9e circonscription
alors oui bien sûr elles ce site ou
situe plutôt dans le nord ouest du
département envie d'elle que c'est une
véritable petite france elle est
essentiellement rural mais concentrent
aussi de grands pôles urbains il se
compose du coup de 88 communes réparties
en 4 content quand on le canton
d'aubergenville de bannières sur scène
de guerville et de houdan plus les
communes des mureaux et de chapet et le
représente à peu près cent quarante et
un mille habitants alors c'est une
circonscription qui a toujours plutôt
pencher vers le centre droit d'abord
avec le rpr rassemblement pour la
république puis l'ump représentée par
henri cuq de 1986 à 2010 puis sophie
primas jusqu'en 2011 c'est ensuite jean
marie tahar du parti les républicains
qui occupera le poste de député jusqu'en
2017 enfin en 2017 c'est bruno millièmes
alors qu'on saigne et conseiller
régional d'ile-de-france sous
l'étiquette modem qui a été élue battant
le député sortant à plus de 54% et
justement un candidat qui se représente
incertaine et will effectivement
candidat à sa propre succession sous
l'étiquette de la majorité
présidentielle donc sous la bannière
ensemble qui regroupe sept partis
politiques dont la république en marche
alors il faut savoir que la 9e
circonscription regroupe beaucoup de
communes qui avaient accordé leur voix
au rassemblement national au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
principalement dans le conte temps dans
le camp tant de bonheur sur scène les
murs aubergenville avaient quant à eux
voté majoritairement jean luc mélenchon
avec 36% aux mureaux et 30% à
aubergenville au premier tour le député
sortant a donc beaucoup de travail à
faire pour retrouver la confiance de ses
habitants et il y aura aussi très autres
candidats donc sept sur sept
circonscriptions c'est là où il ya le
plus de candidats dans les yvelines et
oui en fait ils sont beaucoup à ceux
discutés la 9e circonscription six
femmes contre huit hommes au total alors
parmi les autres candidats on retrouve
babette de rozières conseillère
régionale d'ile-de-france depuis 2015
alors c'est un ancien soutien de valérie
pécresse qui elle avait quitté en pleine
campagne présidentielle
aujourd'hui elle dit représenter la
majorité présidentielle alors qu'elle
n'a eu aucune investiture officielle le
député sortant lui a demandé de modifier
ces tracts de campagne sans succès pour
l'instant à droite c'est pauline
winocour lefebvre membre du parti
républicain qui représentera le parti de
l'union des droites pour les yvelines
conseillère départementale du compte on
du canton d'aubergenville 2015 et vice
présidente du conseil départemental
délégué à la ruralité l'agriculture et
l'alimentation elle se place comme la
principale concurrente du député sortant
à gauche c'est un membre de la france
insoumise victor baia qui représentera
les nubes la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale à seulement 20 ans
c'est un étudiant en 3e année de
philosophie à la sorbonne et le conte
axé sa campagne sur l'écologie et le
bien-être animal on retrouve également
le conseiller régional d'île de france
laurent morin pour le rassemblement
national qui se présente comme la seule
opposition à emmanuel macron christain
fluo pour le parti reconquête d'eric
zemmour ou encore philippe omar pour le
parc pour le parti la lutte ouvrière
merci beaucoup céline charles pour ses
explications journalistes pour tv 78
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre c'est une
grosse opération de recrutement qui
avait lieu aujourd'hui au rectorat de
versailles
en partenariat avec pôle emploi et
l'apec étudiants en fin d'études
personnes en recherche d'emploi ou
encore en reconversion étaient
accueillis autour de deux espaces un
espace de recrutement qui permettait à
ceux qui le souhaitaient de passer un
entretien il ya un espace de rencontre
avec le personnel du rectorat de
versailles pour s'informer et découvrir
les métiers de l'académie au total ce
sont 2000 postes qui sont à pourvoir
pour la rentrée charline avenel vous
êtes avec nous un rectrice de l'académie
de versailles bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes ont fait le point avec vous un
dans un instant vous êtes avec nous
justement pour ce journal mais juste
avant céline charles est allé rencontrer
à des participants ce matin regarder
c'est un événement d'envergure pour
accompagner les projets de recrutement
du rectorat de versailles qui recrutent
2000 personnes sur les métiers de
l'enseignement du professeur des écoles
et professeurs du premier et second
degré également les médecins scolaires
infirmiers scolaires psychologues de
l'éducation nationale et les
accompagnants d'élèves en situation de
handicap
faire le recrutement d'al vsh
accompagnant d'élèves en situation
d'handicap ça permet de rencontrer
beaucoup de monde que ce soit professeur
des écoles à messages ou mêmes notre
discipline là bas il ya un espace de
rencontre qui est vraiment vraiment pas
mal et puis nous ils nous mettent
vraiment dans le bain il nous présente
comment ça va se passer ça nous permet
de nous présenter des êtres humains en
face de nous et nous faire un peu
violence nous même de sortir de notre
confort caché derrière une lettre mais
en même temps ça fait un peu peur en
tant que parents de se dire bah en gros
c'est un gros vivier avec tout et
n'importe quoi donc on vient de le voir
à l'académie de versailles je lui disais
organiser un job dating ce lundi 30 mai
pour préparer la rentrée prochaine
y'avait plus déjà il y avait plus de 400
postes pardon à pourvoir déjà
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer à charline avenel comment ça
s'est passé
ça s'est bien passé ça a été un grand
après
vous m'entendez bien oui je vous entends
je vous entends d'accord donc ça a été
un grand succès on a eu plus de
personnes que nous attendions et voilà
ça témoigne patrick public et émissions
professeurs
et donc face à un moment un moment
d'accueil un moment vont par le métier
on peut donner envie et recrutent mais
un certain nombre nous rejoigne
justement on va revenir à cette journée
en ce job dating qui a lieu aujourd'hui
mais juste avant pour bien comprendre on
fait face à une pénurie qui est pas
nouvelle à une pénurie d'enseignants
comment on explique cette évolution
finalement qui s'est aggravée
alors nous donc versailles on a toujours
beaucoup de personnes à l'accueil d'une
versailles soutenir employeurs 19 et ce
en 2000 personnels donc chaque rentrée
un petit défi et cette année y compris
on rentre ensuite ne fait pas le plein
emploi dans les hauts-de-seine par
exemple on est à moins de pourcentage
donc ça va nous avons à démontrer
l'intérêt de venir vers l'éducation
donc cette tension sur leur poids est
bien qu'à nous-mêmes comme on fire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
souhaité modalités de
est-ce qu'il ya des raisons aussi par
exemple suite à la crise sanitaire ça
peut être aussi aggravé il ya aussi le
fait que le capes ce soit maintenant en
master 2 alors qu'avant on pouvait déjà
le passé en master 1 est ce que ces
choses là aussi ça aggrave où finalement
ça n'impacte pas forcément alors c'est
une année transitoire qui est un petit
peu coup plus compliqué que cette année
mais de toute façon c'est ce que on est
un employeur forme et donc il faut
conquérir notre public ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui est plutôt un truc c'est moi
j'ai vu d'abord beaucoup de monde plus
que deux parce que l'avion puis à
démontrer de l'appétence pour les
métiers ducation nation
donc là pour revenir au job dating qui a
eu lieu donc aujourd'hui on le disait
pourquoi cette méthode de recrutement
c'est un peu étonnant dans le domaine de
l'éducation n'a pas vu souvent c'était
une solution pour pallier justement ce
manque alors le job dating et méthodes
très qualitatif pour le côté très
qualitative parce que on a des jambes
des personnes qui sont là témoigner de
leur expérience
on avait beaucoup de ce matin de la part
de gens quant à nous il voulait savoir
comment ça se passe on traite pendant la
classe comment ils pas des êtres régner
donc le john beattie et abattoirs une
méthode qui nous permet de pouvoir
répondre à beaucoup d'attentes et emmène
porte
donc ça donne une visibilité finalement
c'était quoi les critères pour
participer aujourd'hui tout le monde
pouvait venir où il y avait des critères
en tout cas pour candidater
alors
pour le recrutement mais
aujourd'hui à tous on avait fait un
travail avec pôle emploi pour amener
vers ces journées de top dating des
personnes ici qu'ils sont venus en
connaissance de cause donc il ya eu tout
un partenariat avec leur foi et ça
permet vraiment de préparer et donc on
avait
vraiment qu'ils ont envie de venir vers
vous
et donc llorach on en parlait tout à
l'heure il ya peut-être des gens aussi
qui sont là pour une reconversion on a
entendu un peu les parents qui disait
c'est une bonne chose même temps on est
un peu inquiet parce que finalement ils
n'ont pas forcément l'expérience d'air
ça peut impacter justement la qualité
d'éducation ou pas du tout ils vont être
accompagnés par une formation
[Musique]
alors quand on recrute les contractuels
comme ça évidemment il faut être un
compagnon il faut être présent comme
d'autres accompagnant ce pour le début
des conséquences cela veut dire que les
personnes qui vont nous rejoindre vont
avoir une session accueille enfin un
petit peu avant la rentrée scolaire ils
n'auront d'autres formations pendant
l'année ils auront du tutorat faisaient
pas pour une durée 3 mois là on va être
et puis ils vont avoir accès à des
hommes créé une école à 4000 formation
us et donc tout cela viendra accompagner
c'est absolument est elle bien et on le
doit aux élèves et on le voit
alors juste peut-être pour terminer un
l'académie de versailles regroupe quatre
départements donc les hauts-de-seine
l'essonne le val-d'oise et donc les
yvelines y aura peut-être d'autres job
dating à venir
on a trois
pour les yvelines nous aurons dans la
suite de la semaine le val d'oise essone
les fautes et
garonnais merci et puis comme on a eu
beaucoup de demandes et finalement par
envie de nous rencontrer eh bien nous
allons proposer sur le moi tu vois les
créneaux de recrutement très bien on a
écouté c'est entendu merci beaucoup en
tout cas elle les renseignements sont
disponibles sur le site de l'académie
merci beaucoup et charline amené d'avoir
été avec nous un je le rappelle vous
êtes la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles
[Musique]
et avant de terminer ce journal le
festival de cannes a baissé le rideau ce
samedi 28 mai radio sensations en
partenariat avec tv 60,18 vous a fait
vivre l'événement de l'intérieur en
allant à la rencontre et bien d' acteurs
et producteurs de la région et avant la
clôture de cette grande fête du cinéma
mathis godefroy a rencontré le
réalisateur maga et uri ils ont pu
échanger sur son film les enfants de la
liberté regarder parmi les nombreux
films présentés en marge du festival de
cannes celui de maga ettori réalisateur
des enfants de la liberté un film qui
traite notamment des droits fondamentaux
de l'obligation vaccinale mais pas que
au delà de la problématique de la santé
c'est plus par rapport à la personne
plus par rapport à ce lien douchy qui
est un portrait on a fait un portrait
d'elle on l'a suivi pendant six mois et
sonia c'est quelqu'un qui on l'a vu dans
un premier film puisque les enfants la
liberté c'est une suite sonia c'est
quelqu'un qui a eu d'enfance
très très difficile est en fait qu avait
des rêves mais des rêves de justice
[Musique]
aujourd'hui et se matérialise
à travers ce combat ce combat pour les
pour les droits fondamentaux et en
l'occurrence il s'avère que nous quand
on filme on filme dans le cadre de la
pandémie c'est pas un film sur la
pandémie en fait on m'a pris ma sai on
appris david
m'a tout pris
j'ai encore du mal à réaliser
qu'elle n'est plus là
c'est l'état qui est coupable de la mort
de sofia s'est passé par an qu'on a fait
c'est que dans un premier temps on est
allé interviewer des gens qu'on fait les
loin on a voulu voir si c'était possible
de concilier l'inconciliable
donc on a permis à sonia mme de celle là
président du collectif des blouses
blanches bas de rencontrer ces
parlementaires une grande partie du
court métrage a été tourné dans les
yvelines aux mureaux plus précisément et
c'est pour une bonne raison c'est
essentiellement en ou tout simplement
parce que le collectif blouses blanches
sont piégés et aux mureaux mais après
en suivant sonia parce qu'on l'a suivie
pendant six mois en fait en suivant
sogno effectivement ça a rayonné un
petit peu dans toute la région et c'est
pas simplement c'est pas simplement sur
la problématique du vaccin c'est aussi
sur la problématique des quartiers par
exemple pour maggaiez tories ce film est
avant tout l'histoire d'une mère de
famille devenant leader d'opinion dans
un contexte particulier c'est la fin de
ce journal merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi dans un instant retrouver michael
et demi d'euros à la présentation de
votre magazine sportif très bonne soirée
à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]